aujourd'hui les livres québécois sont en
vedettes en vitrine
depuis six ans le 12 ou est devenue une
date incontournable pour les libraires
le 12 ou c'est vraiment une fête c'est
vraiment comme un aigle en plein été on
était tous fébriles moi d'ailleurs
j'arrive de vacances ma première journée
je rentre plutôt justement pour être là
pour le 12 parce que c'est une journée
vraiment particulière cette initiative
lancée en 2014 sur les médias sociaux
par deux auteurs rapidement été adopté
par les lecteurs oui j'ai fait un détour
aujourd'hui pour venir dans une
librairie indépendante afin d'acheter
mon lit québécois annuel j'en achète
d'autres durant l'année mais la journée
d'aujourd'hui est particulièrement
important à notre librairie fait que je
sais d encourager le plus possible vu
ses 12 ou d'acier donne un petit coup de
pouce sont bien quand même à chaque
semaine je pense pas que c'est
aujourd'hui le doudouk on devrait juste
acheté un livre québécois selon les
données recueillies par la société de
gestion de la banque de titres de langue
française le 12 ou 2018 les ventes de
fiction québécoise aurait été multiplié
par quatre par rapport à une journée
normale
c'est en augmentation chaque année on
est un peu inquiet aujourd'hui parce que
tu as le lundi on se dit ah bon c'est en
début de semaine les gens reviennent de
vacances peut-être que ça va être moins
populaire et non contraire ça ne
dérougit pas depuis ce matin
pour l'auteur simon boulerice le doudou
est une occasion de se faire un cadeau
je vois cette journée là comme une
célébration du livre non pas comme un
encouragement qui peut paraître un peu
paternaliste anges
on n'a pas besoin d'encouragements on a
juste besoin d'être lu et d'être mis de
l'avant c'est pas un don c'est un bon
deal pour l'acheteur parce que lire un
livre c'est une réflexion s'est on est
ému on est bouleversé on est henri notre
littérature propose des thèmes variés et
des histoires qui nous ressemblent mais
libre à vous le diront il ne faut pas se
contenter d'acheter des livres le 12 ou
seulement c'est à l'année longue qu'il
faut soutenir et profiter de notre
littérature d'ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal